In summer 2018, Secretary of Education
Betsy DeVos announced new guidelines on
a provision of the federal student loan
program known as "borrower defense to
repayment." DeVos fixed a bizarre piece of
Obama era guidance which allowed the
Secretary of Education to grant
across-the-board loan forgiveness to
all borrowers in a program, even to those
who could not show any evidence of harm.
Predictably, Devos's move was met with
the usual hysteria, but these critiques
were both inaccurate and unfair. After
all, the whole point is that it's not
clear that all borrowers seeking loan
forgiveness actually have been
defrauded. And since the Obama rules made
no meaningful effort to distinguish
between accidental misinformation and
deliberate fraud, colleges were about to
become pinatas for target hungry lawyers,
with taxpayers stuck footing the bill.
DeVos got this one right. The new
rules make more sense for colleges, tax
payers, and students willing to repay
their debts.
How do you think we should
best balance the needs of student
borrowers and taxpayers? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.